I think at this point Democrats are
probably excited for the prospect of
getting rid of Biden and getting
something I heard that one before yeah I
mean you've heard people saying that
basically it's like here's how you get
rid of the guy because because
apparently he's playing on running again
he's already campaigning and it's like
he's in a weak position if it ends up
being DeSantis against a bite it I don't
think Biden wins
I I I agree that he's probably too old
to run for a second term I I would I
would love for the Democrats to nominate
somebody that's younger
um I I think that if it was Trump Biden
I think Biden would win I think if it
was DeSantis Biden I think Biden's going
to have a difficult time who would you
guys vote for uh DeSantis or Biden it's
still Biden okay why though just because
I I agree more with his views
well I I can certainly understand from
like especially the culture war and all
that stuff but uh
what has Biden done or what are his
views that you think are are good or
that are worth giving a second term to I
I think he's done a lot a lot of good I
I think that uh I mean I could name
several things I think the chips act
which brought manufacturing of computer
chips back the United States I think
that's great for manufacturing here but
also great for uh I think our national
security uh the pack DAC with the burn
pit thing which he signed and do law
the uh the cap on senior uh prescription
drug costs at two thousand dollars I
think that's great I think there's a lot
of old people in the United States who
aren't even buying drugs that they need
because of the expenses and I I I love
the fact that he signed that new law a
lot of these things I think you know
before the show we were talking about
how uh we had Destiny on what's his name
Steve Steve Benelli Benelli yeah I
thought it was Bonnell isn't it I
thought there's an island but uh you
know I was saying like obviously on a
lot of core issues like Healthcare you
know rights of the workers bringing jobs
back bringing chip manufacturing like
we're gonna that's a good one by the way
oh I think it's Stephen Bonnell the
second so I thought that was an eye
sorry Steve there you go I was like I
was wait was not in there but uh one of
the issues I take uh
the most important thing foreign policy
for me I often go off on foreign policy
like we had a lot of Eli Yahoo he's a
reporter for us and then we got into a
yelling match because he's like he
called himself jokingly the resident
neocon because he was saying like we
should be at war in these countries we
should be stopping communism we should
be it should be a unipolar world where
the U.S is in control and my attitude is
kind of like okay I get that I
understand why you'd argue that but I'm
I'm pretty much against U.S intervention
in all these countries effectively
invading countries to remove their
government and their cultures and impose
our own will and stuff like that so when
it comes to Joe Biden you know I've seen
what Joe Biden did in in when he was
vice president and it was I I I think
corruption is an understatement right as
soon as he gets he gets put in charge of
the war in Iraq his brother gets
lucrative contracts we see the expansion
of the wars in the Middle East under the
Obama Administration we see the Drone
killings of children which okay fine
that's you know that's on Barack Obama
like the killing of Abdullah another
lucky but also other American citizens
like Anwar alaki under Donald Trump we
certainly had some bad things there's a
Commando right in Yemen which the people
their claim killed an eight-year-old
American Girl
it's a bad claim it's not the same thing
as what we know that Obama did Kill
Abdul Rahman al-alalaki but then Trump
tries negotiating peace with North Korea
actually walking through the DMZ into
North Korea with no security detail he
gets us the Abraham Accords he gets you
know uh pulling our troops out of Syria
at least as much as he could without the
U.S military actually lying to him and
us about how many troops we had there
setting a timeline for Afghanistan
withdrawal so those things for me are
extremely important and I can certainly
understand you know you've mentioned
those domestic policies but I'm curious
your thoughts on that regard I mean when
it comes to war Joe Biden is in my
opinion indefensible
yeah I mean you bring up some good
points about International policy and I
I tend to focus more on National stuff
stuff that's happening in our country
I'm I'm pretty much against War too so I
mean it's hard to argue with some of
that stuff uh you know I mean how many
wars are we in right now oh man we don't
even know about it yeah a lot of them
are clandestine a lot of them are
secrets that's because of Donald Trump a
lot of that's well there's the proxy
there's the proxy these drone Wars
I I want to expand on that because
there's the proxy war in Ukraine there's
also expanded operations right now in
Africa there's limited operations in
Syria uh very limited uh covert Ops in
Libya
um always a troop presence in um Iraq
still with fighting between the Sunni
shiis and the Iranians also getting
involved there
um a couple years ago we were bombing
places in the Philippines I don't know
if we're still doing that now a lot of
this again is covert so we moved from
over War to of course a lot of
clandestine more limited War the we kind
of implemented the Henry Kissinger
Doctrine and to answer your question uh
there's probably a lot more Wars that
we're involved in that we actually know
about yeah and I and I I just mean
official Wars we got out of Afghanistan
of course but no and and
um
anti-interventionist I I don't think we
should be dabbling in all these
countries I I don't have a
a negative opinion on us helping Ukraine
though I I think that
given given what's happening over there
I think we do need to help them just so
that Russia's aggression doesn't spread
throughout the rest of Europe uh I I
mean I I hate to see us supplying
weapons that are killing people but at
the same time I fear more what Russia
would do if they went unchecked well how
do you feel about Us's direct
involvement in Ukraine with our
spiritual forces on the ground
I I don't I wouldn't I wouldn't like
that well that's happening right now and
also Ukrainian soldiers are being sent
to Oklahoma in order to get specific
American training I also forgot one very
important war and that's the war in
Yemen which is still continuing right
now it's a larger proxy war between the
United States and Saudi Arabian
Coalition which is creating one of the
worst humanitarian crises in the world
right now I think these issues do matter
and and I think not a lot of people take
them seriously because they happen
outside of the United States but I
definitely think we definitely need more
of a conversation about this because the
war in Ukraine it's it's it's a very
dangerous situation and I understand
that you know a lot of people are vying
for influence or vying for territory or
vying for power but I think it's clearer
than ever if you guys agree or disagree
that the United States and other Western
powers like the United Kingdom have
prevented peace deals have prevented a
stop to this larger proxy conflict and
have prolonged it and are prolonging it
by giving more weapons to it making sure
that it won't it won't stop anytime soon
which I think is tragic for the people
of Ukraine tragic for the people in
Europe and also tragic for everyone else
in the world that's of course this
larger proxy war is also creating a
humanitarian crisis when it comes to
energy resources fertilizer and
affecting some of the poorest people uh
in the world you have a a peace deal
between Russia and Ukraine would require
Ukraine to give Russia something that
they didn't have before the war started
right and and I mean when it comes to
peace deals in the negotiations every
side has to give something up so Russia
would give something up Ukraine would
give something up I mean we reached the
point where even Henry Kissinger uh an
absolute war criminal The Butcher of
Cambodia is coming out publicly saying
guys this is getting out of hand we need
a peace deal here so when it comes to
negotiations both both of the parties
are going to have to concede on
something but it's hard to say okay you
know Russia is should gain for invading
Ukraine like so if they agree to a peace
deal now what to stop them from two
months later saying we're invading again
and we're gonna inch farther and we want
another peace deal and we're going to do
the same thing in another tomb you know
if you give if you give Russia something
they're going to be like we can get
something and they're I mean yeah
something well that's that's what they
would be saying on the other side too
this is the Perpetual yeah giving up
their land not always that's one
potential stipulation but the first
original peace deal that was actually
sabotaged by the West Was that uh Russia
go back to its original territories
before uh the War uh started and then we
had Boris Johnson come to Ukraine and
said no way you're agreeing to the
specific peace deal so what are the
parameters I mean you're you're bringing
up one parameter if that's on the
negotiation table it at least should be
negotiated but we're even prevented from
coming to the table and negotiating
which I think is absolutely crazy and
rooting for more war when there's so
many things at stake here when there's
so many innocent lives being lost here
is just absolutely crazy in my opinion
and this is my answer you know you're
mentioning like you concerned more about
domestic policy and I can I completely
understand that but how many years was
it where Flint's pipes were not fixed
and these kids are getting you know
there's like legionnaires in the older
population LED another contaminants and
now we're learning in a bunch of
different cities across this country so
that's why when when AOC first announced
the green New Deal when it was very very
rudimentary when it was just like this
idea of we're going to rebuild
infrastructure and massively invest in
renewable energies I was 100 on board I
was like this sounds amazing then she
puts out this document where it's like
once we do away with Air transport and
farting cows which I understand was a
joke but I was just like I don't
understand what free free college for
people of color has to do with fixing
pipes in places like flint and the
response I got from people a lot of
people on the left was well it's all
tied to the same problem and I'm like no
no it literally isn't kids are drinking
lead and instead of spending that you
know was it 30 million dollars or
however which was going to cost to fix
these pipes we're blowing up people in
foreign countries and I think the reason
we're doing it is because the U.S will
do anything to maintain the Petro dollar
that the the the world Reserve currency
will stay the US dollar so we give money
away to Pakistan for gender studies
programs because as it means they'll
spend it because it means everyone will
maintain confidence so we neglect the
things that are actually going on here
at home they throw crumbs out meanwhile
the southern border is completely just
shattered and you've got this you've got
people and children dying in the river
crawling to the desert they ignore those
issues it feels like they're just
offering up whatever they can to keep
people placated while they actually
siphon away the resources from the
people in this country for the issues of
blowing people up overseas and more
importantly when it comes to Ukraine my
view of Ukraine is to go back to what
you were saying about Ukraine went to
give something up I don't I don't
actually view it that way and this is
kind of a hard thing to say because I
have Ukrainian friends and it's really
difficult to talk to them about this but
Ukraine wouldn't be giving up anything
because there is no Ukraine there's a
proxy land between Russia and United
States it's been there since the fall of
the Soviet Union and the U.S and Russia
I should say nato and Russia have been
playing dirty games in that territory
Russia regrets giving it up with the
fall of the Soviet Union they think was
a mistake they need Crimea as a warm
water Port access to the black C to the
Suez Mediterranean Etc et cetera and
they're mad that happened so they want
to take that first then they're running
the risk because they only have that
bridge so they want a land bridge that's
why they want the donbass region the
United States of course is doing
influence operations through usaid and
other organizations in Ukraine to gain
influence you end up in 2014 I'm
actually there I'm interviewing people
about this yes many of ukrainians
outright are like we would rather be
with the EU than Russia because we
remember the Soviet Union and it was bad
but then the president gets removed
flees to Russia you get zelenski instead
you get the whole Fiasco with barisma
Hunter Biden Joe Biden and all of that
corruption and then I look at it like
you've got barisma on Energy company
surprise surprise gazprom has
effectively an a monopoly in in Europe
it's Russia's Monopoly through gas
problem through Ukraine the U.S starts
putting its its resources and assets
into Ukraine in the energy sector
notably Hunter Biden as well as a former
CIA uh director or something working at
barisma a prosecutor Victor shulkin is
then investigating Michaela zlachevski
the founder of this company for
corruption I think 12 to 14 different
investigations Joe Biden then flies
there says if you don't fire the
prosecutor you're not getting the
billion dollars which is an illegal quid
pro quo I'm not saying he did it to
protect his son but his son did work for
the company did make money from that the
investigations were happening and it was
illegal for him to do
everything together and I'm just like
you know what I see I see a guy Joe
Biden who when he was the vice president
was placed in charge of the war in Iraq
and then immediately his brother got
lucrative multi-million dollar contracts
to build housing in other buildings and
other Construction in that country
surprise surprise a Politico wrote an
article called Biden Inc where they go
over all of the lucrative deals the
Biden families just fallen into
in relation to the position of Joe Biden
so now we're looking at Ukraine Joe
Biden's dumping a hundred plus billion
dollars just constantly saying give more
money give more money give more money
zelenski is refusing to negotiate and
saying we will not Surrender by the way
U.S give us more money and I'm sitting
here being like can we fix our border
can we fix the pipes can we make sure
these kids are getting clean drinking
water can we stop blowing up people
overseas my view of this whole thing is
that you've got a corrupt parasite class
like Joe Biden and and not just him but
many of the Republicans as well and they
just seek to extract as much as possible
for themselves and I think what they're
probably doing at this point is
transferring their resources to like
Panama because we learned it from the
Panama papers so they can put it in
holding so that when the U.S finally
implodes because they've extracted
everything they can they're gonna send
it over to China where State capitalism
will favor them long story short
it's a good story
well okay so I I mean I I don't disagree
that we shouldn't that we should be
concentrating more on
America and what's happening in this
country
um a lot of your Joe Biden stuff I
disagree with I think that Victor shoken
was pretty much wanted to be the whole
Western World our allies all wanted him
ousted because he was a corrupt
prosecutor and he wasn't actually
Prosecuting people he should have been
Prosecuting but like who I mean if we're
talking about corrupted politicians in
Ukraine there's all Ukraine is known for
corruptive politicians you know but
sorry these guys to address that I can
agree right the the West did want Victor
shoken out that was the policy the issue
is that when Victor shulkin got ousted
Michael zlachevski this is what Biden
said he said he wasn't Prosecuting the
guy he wasn't going after him so we got
rid of him they bring in a new guy and
zlachevski returns so so the uh I think
it was London froze uh zlachevsky's
assets
Victor shulkin gets removed by Biden
zlachevsky immediately returns to
Ukraine to resume his work and then when
Trump gets in and starts poking around
zlachevski flees the country again so it
I I'm just I'm not going to believe this
argument that well we really wanted him
out when removing him actually helped
the guy that was supposedly the corrupt
guy in the first place it just doesn't
it doesn't make sense at all I I mean
you can you can come up you can say you
know Hunter Biden was working in Ukraine
it's corrupt he was feeding money back
to Joe Biden I mean you could say I'm
not even saying any of that but I mean I
mean people do right right but my point
is you've got a CIA director you've got
Hunter Biden CI director's name by the
way is Joseph kofer black he was on the
board right yeah they put him on the
board and so it's it's like look man
here I'll tell you what I think I don't
think in this instance uh that it's
overtly like Joe Biden's getting 10 for
the big guy with his son I think it's
that Europe didn't want to pay
exorbitant prices for natural gas but
Russia's got him by the balls the U.S
wanted to build a pipeline through Syria
on turkey called the cutter turkey
pipeline Syria said our Ally Russia
would be mad at us if we let you do that
so we won't surprise surprise we get
lucky and a civil war erupts in Syria
which is going to basically grant us
access Russia of course has their base
in Tartus creating all sorts of conflict
I think the U.S wants to get cheaper
energy into Europe they want to
strengthen the European Union with more
energy with with more Economic
Development because they want a stronger
block to compete with China in a certain
sense I'm not necessarily trusting all
of all of the elites I think I mean I
agree with you there I think that's
that's part of the U.S plan yeah right
it's a big component and when Syria was
was not willing to abide by uh these
these you know these this offer I
suppose let's just call it convenient
that there's a massive destabilization
in the west is of course against Bashar
al-assad then when it comes to the fact
that gas prom runs I think 20 of natural
gas through Ukraine the U.S all of a
sudden has this interest in getting rid
of a corrupt prosecutor who happens to
have like 12 to 14 investigations into
the founder of an energy company where
Joe Biden's son and a CIA director are
currently on the board
I think the U.S is trying to gain
control of energy makes a lot of sense
Russia's competing with them they're
using Ukraine as a proxy
I get it man you know it's tough because
I don't want the US to falter I don't
want China to rise and take over and
then we have Chinese state communism but
I also take a look at Joe Biden flying
Hunter to China on Air Force 2 for
private Equity deals and I'm just like I
don't trust them at all on any of this
yeah like I mean I understand that and I
definitely think what you said is
correct that the US has a lot of
interest in keeping the US dollar value
up because without it being up we can
lose ground to China and our other
adversaries but the whole like you know
I think their right is quick to push us
this Joe Biden Hunter Biden corruption
thing like the 10 for the big guy that
deal right that deal never took place
that deal never actually went through
and Joe was a private citizen at the
time that the email was who in a
subsequent email said I don't want
anything to do with this I mean so Joe
also lied about his involvement
repeatedly yeah he lied he well he
either lied or he did things were kind
of uh I mean went over so he said that
he never talked to his son about any of
his business deals and then there's him
with his son and his buddies
that doesn't mean he had a business
conversation with him maybe he went to
his bank accounts no I'm saying with
this with this guy no no I know but like
yeah they share a bank they and emails
and tax and phone numbers so it's just
like come on man okay I mean but that's
all you can jump to these conclusions
that yeah since he said 10 for a big guy
he was doing other deals you know since
he got the since he said Shogun should
get fired it was because Hunter was
working for brisma and maybe that's the
reason why you know there should be more
less
children of presidents working in other
countries I mean you could say there's
plenty of instances with Kushner and
Ivanka and I mean what about the the 666
Fifth Avenue deal in New York when
Kushner couldn't get anybody given
release and Qatar comes along right when
Saudi Arabia is blockading Qatar and
then Trump lifts the blockade as soon as
Kushner gets a 1.4 billion dollars so I
mean but there's no evidence that it's
there are two are linked but you could
definitely come up with ideas that
there's corruption going on right I mean
I I think the the issue is as it
pertains to Biden or Trump a fair point
is yeah it's always a pick your poison
right Donald Trump uh I don't know
exactly how this goes down and and again
a lot of this requires speculation but I
think there's a state department website
advertising Trump Doral or something
like that I don't know if you guys
remember that no there yeah it was like
a state department website was like stay
at Trump Resorts or something and and
people were like yo what the is going on
like you shouldn't be doing that Trump
wanted to have I think the G7 at Trump
Doral in Florida oh yeah and then he got
back lash was like no I certainly think
you see a lot of this kind of stuff but
I think when it came to Donald Trump
there was actually this despite much of
his shortcomings which I certainly think
there are many of Crossing into North
Korea that was really big for me
crossing the DMZ the Abraham Accords I
think were really really big I certainly
think they're questions I think anybody
who comes out and says that there's no
like that like Trump or any anybody who
who says like oh the bidens weren't
really doing this or the trumps weren't
really doing this I'm going to be like
dude everybody's always going to be
thinking about themselves to a certain
degree so my issue is after assessing
all the details I take a look at the
Biden family and Biden Inc as political
magazine called it I take a look at the
history of this guy his plagiarism and
the fortunes his families have tracked
along with his positions in government
and it's just like okay this guy is just
literally extracting from us Donald
Trump lost money becoming president like
his net worth has dropped he's lost
millions of dollars his tax returns
actually showed on paper right but you
don't know he could have foreign
business deals that are
being taxed in other countries his
social capital is off the off the charts
right now as well I mean
celebrity yeah he made five million
dollars at the nfts his amazing nfts
yeah they were really funny I mean
Cowboy Trump get a cowboy Trump get an
astronaut did he get one I did not get
one I would not buy an nft 100 bucks
each is that what they 100 bucks each
yeah and sold them all with them and
that was like you know I don't know man
I think he dropped in the predicted
Market by like 10 cents when he did that
because it was like I followed that too
yeah I posted a picture of one of his uh
one of his supporters riding in jail and
him looking through the cell be like hey
you guys want to buy some nfts so uh I
mean talking about foreign policy here a
little bit there's corruption on both
sides I mean Jared Kushner was
negotiating better weapons deals for
Saudi Arabia all right that's a lot of
corruption there with with North Korea
John Bolton sabotaged any possibilities
of peace talks by comparing North Korea
saying that they're going into the
Libyan model of foreign policy but again
you could always compare the two but I I
think it's fair to say that
um the the Biden presidency has a lot
more room for corruption because he's a
career politician he's been in office he
knows everyone he knows all the
diplomats he knows all the bureaucrats
he has a lot more finagling room to do a
lot of really bad stuff and from the
beginning of his political career he has
been known as a man of the lobbyist he
has been giving a lot of special
interest groups a lot of what they
wanted uh specifically the military
industrial complex specifically big
Pharma specifically a lot of the bigger
agencies that are now coming in through
the bigger problems that he caused and
especially in Afghanistan China huge
winner out of all of that they're
gaining all the national resources uh
from Afghanistan with Ukraine BlackRock
is getting all the lucrative contracts
to rebuild that entire country after we
spent so much money bombing the crap out
of it uh and and causing so much chaos
um this is why I think it's important to
look at not just Trump but Biden but any
person in power in a very critical light
and criticize him to the highest degree
but do you guys agree or disagree with
me when it comes to saying get rid of
the lobbyists like yeah but but do you
guys agree that that Biden has more of a
more room to be corrupted than Trump who
hasn't been in politics that long I I
think that one of the appeals of trump
in 2016 was that he wasn't connecting a
lobbyists and I can see that as an
appeal but I don't know if that
necessarily means that he's not going to
be looking out for himself and his
businesses I I think owning a bunch of
businesses around the world and having
those businesses profit whether it's
financially or from from a standpoint of
getting name recognition for those
businesses I I think that that can lead
to just as much corruption
um so I I don't know I I think it's
definitely a problem in politics I think
that a lot of people in politics are
selfish and they're out for themselves
rather than out for the country I think
that money in politics is one of the
reasons it's like that I'd like to see
super Pacs go away and I'd like to see
money come out of politics
oh the whole the Trump Biden
conversation is like cat poop or dog
poop what do you want I'm like I'm not
hungry man this is why I don't like any
of them personally I'm like none of them
I don't want I don't want the dog crap I
don't want the poop one thing that
bothers me I view it that way I I I
disagree I I think Biden is like a moldy
sandwich where you're like I know it's
bad and you shouldn't eat it and Trump
is like well look man it's it's not the
healthiest thing in the world for you
but it's food thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time